hey uh there's a decent chance that if  you're seeing this you probably came to  the channel expecting the next take two  doctor who review because i finished  series 11. i did resolution series 12  next well  yes but not immediately i basically i'm  taking the opportunity to take a brief  break as i try and catch up on some  other stuff that i've been trying to get  done for a while and  this just seemed like the ideal place to  do it since  this is just an actual breaking point  between series little break don't worry  it's coming back and it'll be back  before the end of july but for right now  it is going uh on the back burner and it  is going to be a little bit saturday  videos will be unaffected those will go  up as normal but for now at least  this is on pause don't worry  it shall return  see ya